ils étaient près de 3000 à participer au
festival du jeu de villepreux le
week-end dernier enfin participer est un
faible mot les uns se sont battus avec
vigueur d'autres ont beaucoup réfléchi
et certains ont même voyagé jeu là c'est
des objectifs à aden saidal égard à une
autre ou d'une ville d'une ville à une
autre ville en europe
jeu de rôle de plateau figurines jeux
vidéo animation combat il y en avait
pour tous les goûts et l'entrée du
festival était gratuite villepreux a
lancé la manifestation l'an dernier
suite au succès des soirées jeux de sa
médiathèque on se rend compte que de
plus en plus les gens ont besoin de de
s'amuser de sortir pas forcément très
loin de chez eux à des coûts réduits
jouer c'est en fait l'un des trucs qui
plaît le plus au cerveau et tous les
gens qui viennent ici même ce qu'ils
disent s'ils savaient même pas jouer
trouve en fait
matière à réflexion et à rencontre ici
tous les univers coexistent de star wars
au monstre médiévaux il n'y a qu'un pas
les esprits et roanne avec à s'abstenir
on est dans un univers médiéval
fantastique où différents peuples
s'affrontent pour accomplir des missions
divers et variés donc préétabli avant la
partie villepreux devrait reconduire le
festival l'an prochain vous l'aurez
compris pour s'échapper de son quotidien
rien de tel qu'un bon jeu de société